bonjour arnaud benedetti merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
alors comment on vous analyser
l'intervention du premier ministre et
plusieurs de ses ministres cet après
midi pour écouter c'était vrai faux
suspense on savait de toute façon qu'à
partir du moment et plus longs sont
rapprochés que cette date du 11 mai
avait été fixée que l'exécutif ne
pouvait pas faire autrement que tenir
cette date
le premier ministre a rappelé que
c'était un exercice qui finalement
s'opérer sur une ligne de crête très
spécifique entre à la fois la nécessité
d'un retour progressif à une nuit
normale mais en même temps en tenant
compte de l'impératif sanitaires on voit
que le premier ministre a essayé avec
les principaux départements ministériels
qui sont en première ligne dans la
gestion de cette épreuve épidémique de
dresser disons un exposé de la manière
dont le décor finement se déroulerait à
la fois de manière différenciée quand
même en fonction des territoires on voit
bien qu'il ya deux points durs qu'ils
restent qui sont quand même
l'ile-de-france est plutôt le le grand
test et puis bien évidemment mayotte
pour l'outre-mer et on voit que les
sujets sensibles ont été les uns après
les autres screen et durant cet exposé
c'est à dire la question des transports
la question de l'école la question
également d'aider des déplacements
puisque vous parlez de l'école on va
écouter jean michel blanquer a précisé
que les enseignants reprendront le
chemin des écoles le lundi 11 mai donc
l'un des prochains que les enfants
seront accueillis à partir de mardi
prochain un million d'enfants qui sont
concernés le ministre a détaillé de
façon la façon dont les élèves vont
retourner progressivement en classe avec
des différents selon qu'on l'a précisé
la couleur des départements on écoute
jean michel blanquer
bien entendu cette rentrée n'est pas une
rentrée ordinaire s'était d'ailleurs
même pas une rentrée c'est une reprise
et chacun comprend bien que tout ceci
doit être progressif
chaque enfant se trouvent dans quatre
situations possibles à certains moments
il peut être à l'école en petits groupes
avec ses camarades
vous le savez ces groupes ne dépasse pas
15 à l'école élémentaire et 10 à l'école
maternelle à d'autres moments il peut
être en études quand les locaux le
permettent et qu'il y a des moyens de
surveillance
en troisième lieu il peut se retrouver
dans des locaux périscolaires
ceux ci existent lorsqu'un travail entre
l'éducation nationale et la mairie
permet d'avoir ses activités de sport de
santé de culture ou de civisme et puis
en quatrième lieu ils peuvent être à la
maison
dans le cadre de l'enseignement à
distance à plein temps quand les parents
ont préféré les garder à la maison ou à
temps partiel si il passe une partie du
temps à l'école et l'autre partie du
temps à la maison
ce système évidemment se règlent
localement puisque chaque situation est
particulière et nous allons être
particulièrement attentifs aux élèves
décrocheurs pour qu'ils aillent le plus
possible à l'école ou qu'ils puissent
bénéficier pleinement de l'enseignement
à distance
on est avec vous un an benedetti
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire c'est une grande
inquiétude pour les parents le retour
des élèves
oui ou non à l'école est ce que selon
vous le gouvernement s'est montré
suffisamment rassurant écoutez on voit
bien que sur cette question là la
communication est très prudentes et que
sont fiables et des catégories d'enfants
très spécifique le ministre n'a rappelé
ce sont les enfants qui sont
éventuellement on voie de
déscolarisation duché du confinement il
faudra encore s'assurer qu'ils puissent
revenir à l'école ce qui n'est pas
encore démontré parce qu'on sait qu'en
général les que les enfants qui
décrochent scolairement on dise on se
crée souvent des déterminants sociaux
qui font que ils ne reviendront pas
forcément à l'école du fait de cette
situation tout à fait exceptionnelle que
nous vivons les enfants handicapés et
puis les enfants d'aidés soignants donc
on reste quand même pour l'instant sur
une j'allais dire une clientèle
d'enfants qui si celui-ci se reprendre
cette expression qui reste encore très
très restreinte
moi ce qui m'a quand même frappé dans le
discours du ministre de l'éducation
nationale c'est qu'il advienne ester sur
le fait que cela se faisait en étroite
concertation avec les élus locaux comme
si l'état voulait démontrer que dans
cette affaire du retour des enfants à
l'école
il s'appuyait non seulement sur les mers
mais que l'assentiment des mers était d
or une condition aussi ciné qua none de
ce retour et cela alors arnaud benedetti
que la responsabilité c'est vrai des
décideurs
concernant ce plan déconfinement c'est
une véritable question
sa voix rauque et les parents ou ou
enfin vont vous porter plainte contre
qui justement les maires sont très
inquiets à ce propos donc là peut-être
un manque de clarté de la part du
gouvernement aussi le président de la
république il y a quelques jours n'a pas
parlé lui-même lorsqu'il était en visite
à poissy de ce sujet il a plutôt même
exclu d'ailleurs la question de la
protection judiciaire on voit bien que
il ya cette inquiétude de la part des
élus elle est tout à fait d'ailleurs
légitime parce que c'est quand même
d'une certaine manière une décision que
l'état leur impose
il est clair que maire il est
inoubliable double casquette c'est à la
fois le représentant de ses administrés
mais aussi le représentant de l'état
dans sa commune on se sent bien qu'il ya
une inquiétude de la part du côté des
élus il ya une inquiétude quand même
chose je rappeler au sida par des
parents parce que ce sont les premiers
concernés ce sont leurs enfants est
d'ailleurs un sondage récent indiqué que
deux tiers des parents ne souhaitait pas
vraisemblablement leur envoyer leurs
enfants dans les établissements
scolaires et puis il ya une inquiétude
qui a été largement mise en exergue par
le personnel pas pédagogique parler les
enseignants donc on sent bien que sur
cette question du retour à l'école
la tension reste pour l'instant entière
et que bien évidemment on va voir
comment ça va se passer sur le terrain à
partir de mardi lundi avec la présenter
et mardi avec le retour des des enfants
qui sont susceptibles de revenir dans
les établissements c'est un plan d'eau
de déconfinement qui a été préparé par
jean castex
l'objectif principal c'était quand même
de rassurer les français arnaud
benedetti rassurer globalement les
français me sur notamment la circulation
du virus sur tout le territoire
la changement ya le problème c'est qu'il
ya un changement de ton on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui
l'idée c'est de montrer que finalement
on a réussi on est en train de réussir
le déconfinement et on en fait
l'exécutif est en train de décrire le
storytelling de sa de sa victoire pour
d'une certaine manière dissimulée la
gestion parfois dysfonctionnelle de
cette crise on tient la date ont
progressivement remet en marche la
société et on sait très bien que il y
aura un certain nombre de volets qui
relaieront ce ce discours le le fondu le
fond du problème quand même reste entier
c'est que d'abord ce retour se fait dans
des conditions qui sont très variables
en fonction quand même des territoires
on voit bien que la la il ya une grosse
tension quand même sur les zones où il
ya le plus grand nombre la population et
l'afflux est la plus concentrée
notamment l'ile-de-france qu' un certain
nombre de secteurs pour l'instant ne
sont pas du tout nous rassurer a je
pense au secteur des restaurants au
secteur des cafés au secteur touristique
au secteur culturel pour une grande
punto une grande partie donc il reste
encore beaucoup d'angles morts dans ce
retour à la vie à la vie normale
on revient sur la question des
transports ça reste de là aussi disons
un sujet dont on aura mesuré
le caractère opérationnel de ce qui a
été annoncée seulement lundi parce que
tout simplement tenir la distanciation
sociale lorsque vous êtes dans une
société qui se dé confine ce n'est pas
la même chose que tenir la distanciation
social que lorsque vous êtes dans une
société qui est confiné donc il ya il ya
tout un ensemble de deux sujets sur
lesquels on pourra mesurer le caractère
opérationnel de ce qui a été annoncé
seulement lorsque disons les gens se
seront progressivement des confiné à
l'écouté c'est à l'épreuve du deuil
c'est à l'épreuve du déconfinement qu'on
va mesurer finalement de la pertinence
ou non des mesures qui ont été annoncées
même si on sent très bien que on a un
exécutif qui essaye d'être très
granulaire dans ce riff dans ces
prescriptions et puis il ya quand même
un certain nombre de contradictions qui
reste pourquoi empêcher les déplacements
de plus de 100 km et de laisser quoi
qu'on en dise pour le veuille ou non
même si le ministre de l'intérieur a dit
que les frontières ont été fermées et
jaune le jeu le jeu je ne vois pas en
quoi ils sont fermés aujourd'hui elles
sont fermées à l'intérieur de l'espace
schengen mais à l'extérieur de l'espace
schengen mais pas à l'intérieur et puis
il ya encore deux points à ces fausses
et le traçage des maladies dont ils
olivier veyrat il ya fait allusion et
puis également le nombre de lits en
réanimation l'objectif c'est de dettes
rassemblé que 8,19 et toutes pathologies
confondues là on n'est quand même pas
tout à fait les comptes sont pas encore
bon à ce niveau oui alors il y avait
bien évidemment il ya l'autre sujet qui
est absolument essentiel qui finalement
été assez peu abordée en termes de
chiffres c'est la question des moyens
associés pour réussir le lundi
confirmant on nous présente une carte où
on nous dit que nous avons les capacités
de tests nécessaires pour répondre à la
situation dans laquelle nous allons nous
retrouver à partir du déconfinement mais
en fait que lyon n'a pas de chiffre pour
l'instant je rappelle que le premier
ministre lors d'une conférence
précédente avait annoncé que la france
devait être prête pour le 11 mai a
disposé de 700 me theiss de parts
deux semaines pour conseiller à ceux des
confinement la semaine dernière on nous
annonce est plutôt 450000 donc on n'a
pas aujourd'hui les chiffres là dessus
sur les masques c'est la même chose on a
compris que le pont des masques serait
obligatoire dans les transports mais on
voit bien que là aussi sur la question
des masques on ne sait pas aujourd'hui
quel sera le stock dont la france
disposera il en va de même avec avec la
question de l'offre de soins dans les
hôpitaux doit s'enfoncer très bien
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui permet le
déconfinement c'est une pression moindre
sur l'offre de soin une pression moindre
donc sur les lits en réanimation et
l'autre paramètre c'est la circulation
du virus y sont ces deux paramètres qui
sont les paramètres essentiels qui
permettent ou non disons de décider le
goût le no go du déconfinement merci
beaucoup arnaud benedetti pour